Hast du eine Ahnung,
wie Kinder auf die Welt kommen?
Ich weiss es nicht,
ich muss zuerst Mama fragen.
Ich bin sehr dafür,
dass der Lehrer das macht.
Weil man zu Hause
vielleicht Hemmungen hat,
in die Details zu gehen.
In der Schule nahmen wir
das Thema praktisch nicht durch.
Wir wurden nicht gross aufgeklärt.
Meine Eltern sind eher verklemmt.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Grüezi miteinander.
Ich bin Dr. Ruth Westheimer.
Ich werde versuchen,
Ihre Fragen zu beantworten.
Meine Frau hat grosse Hemmungen,
mich oral zu befriedigen.
Und für mich wäre das
etwas vom Schönsten.
Martin, das ist eine Frage,
die ich auf der ganzen Welt höre.
Es gibt Frauen, die gerne
Oralverkehr mit ihrem Mann hätten.
Sie möchten aber nicht,
dass er oral ejakuliert.
Und darüber muss man eben sprechen -
das kann man nicht einfach erraten.
* Aufgestellte Musik *
Sind beschnittene Männer
bessere oder andere Liebhaber?
* Lachen *
Diese Frage
kriege ich auch sehr oft.
Sexualität ist nicht
zwischen dem Gürtel und den Knien.
Sie ist im Kopf.
Der untere Teil des Körpers folgt -
und muss
mit dem Kopf gemacht werden.
Eine wunderbare Frage.
* Aufgestellte Musik *
Grüezi miteinander. Willkommen bei
Dr. Ruth Westheimer in New York!
Diese Frau hat Millionen
von Menschen aufgeklärt: Dr. Ruth.
Die 91-Jährige
ist die Sexberaterin schlechthin.
In den USA wurde Ruth Westheimer
dank Fernsehen und Radio zum Star.
Ich habe von Anfang an gesagt:
Du musst nie sagen:
"Ich habe eine Frage."
Sag: "Eine Bekannte von mir,
ein Bekannter von mir".
Ein Verwandter - ohne Namen -
habe eine Frage.
Und das hat eingeschlagen.
Weil niemand Angst hatte,
dass jemand die Sprache erkennt,
dass sie am Fernsehen
erkannt werden.
Denn ich habe immer gesagt:
"Es ist nicht wichtig, wer fragt."
Das Wichtige ist,
dass die Fragen beantwortet werden.
Damit die Leute
mehr sexuelles Wissen haben.
Hello everyone!
Hello, hello.
Fernsehshows mit Dr. Ruth
sind der absolute Strassenfeger:
Ist man nicht der Typ zum Heiraten,
wenn man alle Mädchen nach
einem Monat langweilig findet?
Wissen Sie, was ich gedacht habe?
Ich dachte, Sie sagen, dass Sie
nicht der Typ zum Heiraten sind,
weil Sie alle Mädchen
so attraktiv finden.
Auch im Schweizer Fernsehen
spricht sie Klartext über Sex.
Es gibt Frauen,
die zur vollen Befriedigung
mehr als einen Orgasmus brauchen.
Es macht aber nichts,
wenn sie den ersten Orgasmus während
des Geschlechtsverkehrs haben.
Dann kann der Mann mit dem Finger -
oder vielleicht mit dem grossen Zeh
weiter befriedigen, so lange,
bis die Frau befriedigt ist.
Hallo?
- Hallo? - Ja.
Allein das Wort Orgasmus
öffentlich auszusprechen,
ist damals revolutionär.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ruth Westheimers Kindheit
ist geprägt durch den Terror
der Nazis in Deutschland.
Als neunjähriges Flüchtlingskind
kommt sie in die Schweiz nach Heiden.
In dieser Zeit werden ihre jüdischen
Eltern in Auschwitz ermordet.
Nach dem Krieg
zieht es sie nach Palästina.
Später studiert sie in Paris
und den USA Psychologie.
Sie heiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Ein Zufall, dass sie das Thema Sex
zu ihrem Beruf macht.
Mit meinem Hintergrund -
als verflixte Ausländerin,
ich bin als Flüchtlingskind
in die Schweiz gekommen, 1939.
Dann wurde ich Waise, die Eltern
und die ganze Familie kamen um.
Eins wusste ich:
Ich muss etwas machen auf der Welt,
um zu zeigen,
warum ich überlebt habe.
Ich wusste aber nicht,
dass das mit Sex zu tun haben wird.
Das machte sonst kein Mensch.
Ich habe ein Doktorat
an der Columbia
in Familienpsychologie gemacht.
Und ich war sehr gut trainiert.
Dann habe ich gesehen,
dass es da etwas gibt,
worin ich einen Unterschied
machen kann.
Wo ich zeigen kann, dass man
über diese Dinge sprechen darf.
Mit Humor, aber ohne es
ins Lächerliche zu ziehen.
Wenn Sie sagen, Sie hatten
vielleicht noch keinen Orgasmus.
Dann würde ich
zuerst einmal vorschlagen,
dass Sie sich selbst befriedigen.
Denn kein Mann, auch kein Schweizer,
auch nicht der beste Liebhaber -
kann eine Frau zum Orgasmus bringen,
wenn die Frau sich
nicht selbst die Erlaubnis gibt,
dieses Gefühl zu fühlen.
Das war unerhört.
Zumal sexueller Genuss bislang
ausschliesslich dem männlichen
Geschlecht vorbehalten war.
Ob in der Ehe oder ausserhalb -
im Bordell.
Frauen hingegen
hatten keusch in die Ehe zu gehen.
Geschlechtsverkehr war für sie
lediglich zur Reproduktion gedacht.
Lust war für Frauen nicht vorgesehen.
Doch die westliche Gesellschaft
veränderte sich grundlegend
und damit
auch das sexuelle Verhalten.
Das hat mit der Industrialisierung
zu tun.
Die Leute
kamen vom Land in die Stadt.
Die jungen Frauen und Männer,
die in die Stadt kamen,
verloren den Schutz der Familie
ein wenig.
In diesem Sinne kann man sagen:
Die Sexualaufklärung ist in dieser
Phase wie eine Gefahrenabwehr.
Es ging nicht darum,
dass man den Jungen etwas Gutes tun
und ihnen Informationen
liefern will.
Es war viel mehr so,
dass man Angst hatte,
dass sie nicht mehr sittlich leben.
Dass sie zu Prostituierten gehen,
dass die Mädchen schwanger werden -
das wollte man verhindern.
Bei ihrer Recherche über
sexuelle Aufklärung stellt sie fest,
dass nebst der Scham auch darüber
zu reden ein Problem darstellt.
Es kam auch der Anspruch,
nicht nur öffentlich aufzuklären,
sondern, dass auch die Eltern
das übernehmen müssten.
Aber wenn für so lange Zeit
über ein Thema geschwiegen wurde,
wie geht das, dass man in der
Familie plötzlich darüber spricht?
Dass der Vater mit dem Sohn und
die Mutter mit der Tochter spricht.
Das ist ein riesiger Kulturwandel.
Darum wusste man,
dass es schwierig sein würde.
Dann entstand
eine völlig neue Literaturgattung.
Es gab nämlich
ganz viele Broschüren.
Diese versuchten
den Eltern zu vermitteln,
wie man Kinder aufklären müsste.
Erst nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
wird in den USA
zum ersten Mal fundiert
über sexuelles Verhalten geforscht.
Pionier
war der Zoologe Alfred Kinsey.
Um aufklären zu können,
müsse man zuerst wissen,
was die Leute
in ihren Schlafzimmern so treiben,
fanden Kinsey und sein Team.
So kam es zur ersten Studie dieser
Art mit rund 20'000 Testpersonen:
Führt übermässiges Masturbieren
zu vorzeitiger Ejakulation?
Ist es ungewöhnlich, wenn
mein Freund meinen Anus berührt?
Das sind alles
ausgezeichnete Fragen.
Und alle haben die gleiche Antwort:
Ich weiss es nicht.
Die Veröffentlichung
der Studienergebnisse,
die sog. Kinsey-Reports,
schlugen ein wie eine Bombe.
Was damals herauskam -
das war ja schockierend:
Dass die Vorstellungen, die man
hatte, die Norm, die man vertrat,
gar nicht mit seinen Ergebnissen
übereinstimmte.
Die Forschungsresultate boten der
Wissenschaft wertvolle Grundlagen.
Kinsey selber
wurde heftig kritisiert
und sogar vom FBI verfolgt.
Eine Erkenntnis war,
dass das kirchliche Onanieverbot
offenbar munter unterlaufen wurde.
Die Onanie war immer noch verpönt.
Man sagte immer noch,
es sei schädlich für den Körper.
Und er fand in seiner Studie heraus,
dass bis zu 70 % der Jugendlichen
onanieren.
So entstand eine neue Realität.
Ich hätte nie die "berühmte"
Dr. Ruth Westheimer werden können,
ohne Kinsey, Masters und Johnson.
Aber ich war
nicht so daran interessiert,
an diesen Untersuchungen
mitzuwirken.
Ich wollte nur,
dass sie mir die Resultate
der Untersuchungen geben.
Und das taten sie?
- Das taten sie.
Die amerikanischen
Forschungsergebnisse
beeinflussen auch die Schweiz.
In den Schulen über Sex zu reden
ist bis in die 60er-Jahre ein Tabu.
Wagte es ein Lehrer, im Schwimm-
unterricht über Sex zu sprechen,
wurde im Fernsehen
über ihn berichtet.
So Jungs, wir haben vereinbart,
dass wir heute in der Schwimmstunde
einmal über Selbstbefriedigung
sprechen.
Wird man krank davon?
- Ich finde, es ist keine Sünde.
Ich hörte,
man kann keine Kinder mehr bekommen.
Ich denke, die Onanie
wird von Gott nicht bestraft.
Wird man dumm davon?
Zur letzten Frage kann ich gleich
sagen: Dumm wird man nicht davon.
Und krank wird man davon auch nicht.
Ich selbst finde auch,
dass es keine Sünde ist.
Früher dachte man, man werde
irrsinnig, es sei etwas Schlimmes.
Ich finde, das Beste ist,
nicht damit anzufangen.
Das ist die einfachste Lösung.
Darum rede ich so früh mit euch.
Damit ihr euch
noch entscheiden könnt,
ob ihr anfangen wollt - Urs?
Besser Onanie
als die Mädchen zu belästigen?
Ja, da bin ich einverstanden,
das ist wahr.
Bezeichnend:
Auch beim fortschrittlichen Lehrer
geht es bei den Buben um Sexualität,
bei den Mädchen
in erster Linie um Biologie.
Ich darf jeweils nicht turnen,
weil ich die Menstruation habe.
Wo beginnt das denn,
diese Periode?
Sonja?
- Im Eierstock.
Im Eierstock. Wie beginnt es?
Brigitte? - Wenn sich das Ei
aus dem Eierstock löst.
Im Eierstock hat es viele Anlagen
von Eiern, wisst ihr wie viele?
Zu Hause
sollten Eltern ihre Kinder aufklären,
wussten aber selbst nicht Bescheid.
Das war die Stunde von Oswalt Kolle.
In den 1960er-Jahren werden
seine Aufklärungsbücher und -filme
für Erwachsene zum Verkaufsschlager.
Ist es dir ganz egal,
was ich dabei fühle?
Na hör mal,
war es vielleicht nicht schön?
Ich spüre nichts.
Ich verstehe es selbst nicht.
- Bestimmt ist die Pille schuld.
Bist du so sicher?
Ja, bei den anderen Mädchen
klappte es immer.
Dann geh doch zu den anderen,
geh doch!
Kino-Aufklärungsfilme
sind in der Schweiz zwar beliebt.
In Zürich werden sie aber
aus moralischen Gründen verboten.
Mir wurde gesagt, dass der
Polizeipräsident von Zürich sagte:
"Das wird verboten - wir lassen uns
nicht von einem Deutschen erklären,
wir wir uns hier im Bett
zu verhalten haben."
Sie müssen sich die Stimmung
für junge Leute heute vorstellen.
Einer der Zensoren sagte:
"Herr Kolle, wollen Sie denn die
ganze Welt auf den Kopf stellen?"
"Jetzt soll sogar die Frau
schon oben liegen!"
Wunderbar, Herr Kolle!
Bravo, weil dann die Klitoris sehr
viel besser berührt werden kann.
Heidi, zieh bloss
diese dämlichen Stiefel aus.
Als Sohn eines Psychiaters
bin ich schon sehr früh
auf das Thema Sexualität gestossen.
Die Psychiatrie
war immer eine Reparaturanstalt
für eine verkrüppelte Sexualität.
Eine Sexualität, die durch die
Gesellschaft, durch die Prüderie,
durch eine Gegenaufklärung
die Menschen kaputt gemacht hat.
Wunderbar! Schade,
dass ich ihn nicht gekannt habe.
Ich bin sehr einverstanden mit ihm.
Denn die Psychiatrie
brauchte eine lange Zeit,
bis sie anerkannt hat, dass man
offen über Sexualität sprechen kann.
Umfragen in den 70er-Jahren zeigen:
Die Kinder haben vielleicht
eine Ahnung von Sex,
aber praktisch kein Wissen.
Wenig erstaunlich,
auch den Eltern fehlt das Vokabular.
Wie kommt denn das Kind
in den Bauch der Mutter?
Vom Vater kommt es zu der Mutter
hinüber, dann bekommt sie es, oder?
Weisst du,
wie Kinder zur Welt kommen?
Sie kommen beim Po heraus.
Und wo sind sie,
bevor sie zur Welt kommen?
Im Bauch.
Und wie sie hineinkommen,
weisst du nicht?
Nein.
Und wie kommt es in den Bauch?
* Unverständliches Flüstern *
Von unten?
Wenn Mann und Frau sich gern haben.
So entsteht das Kind ja.
Klärten Sie Ihre Kinder auf oder
hatten Sie Hemmungen bei Details?
Ich habe nur eine Tochter.
Ich habe ihr ein Aufklärungsbuch
aufs Bett gelegt.
Später fragte ich, ob sie es gelesen
hatte und sie sagte ja.
Ich habe sie aufgeklärt - aber bei
den Details hatte ich Hemmungen.
Ich kläre sie schon auf -
einfach, was sie gerade fragen.
1971 gab es eine Rekrutenbefragung.
Da haben drei von fünf Männer
gesagt, sie seien nicht aufgeklärt
oder nur völlig am Rande.
D.h. es war Theorie, darum fand man,
die Schule müsste dies übernehmen.
Natürlich neben den Broschüren,
die entstanden sind.
Die "Bravo",
die auch in die Lücke sprang.
Informationsmaterialien gab es viele
für die neue Norm, die Ausrichtung.
Aber dann eben die Sexualaufklärung
in der Schule.
Wir sprechen heute über die
Geschlechtsorgane bei Mann und Frau.
Hier haben wir zwei Bilder.
(Originalton) Statt sinnlos gegen
wachsende Sexualität zu predigen,
hat sich dieser Primarlehrer eine
viel schwerere Aufgabe gestellt.
Mit in sein Lehrprogramm einbezogen
hat er für Buben und Mädchen
die sexuelle Aufklärung - nicht als
Schulfach von 9-10 oder 14-15 Uhr,
sondern als zwanglosen Bestandteil
seines Erziehungsprinzips.
Was bedeutet, dass sich Anknüpf-
ungspunkte zu solchen Gesprächen
jederzeit ergeben können.
1971 fiel das Schweizer
Pornografieverbot
und nur Wochen später eröffnete
der erste Sexshop der Schweiz.
(Originalton) Aufklärende Literatur,
die für den Laien verständliche
Sexualinformationen liefert,
bildet den Schwerpunkt des Angebotes
in dem Laden.
Dabei wird
zwischen Anfängerliteratur
und Aufklärung für Fortgeschrittene
unterschieden.
Erotische Inhalte breiteten sich
im öffentlichen Raum immer mehr aus.
Nackte Haut sogar am Kiosk.
Und damit stieg die Sorge um eine
mögliche Sexualisierung der Jugend.
Und genauso wie heute
warnte man schon damals:
(Originalton)
Auch behütete Kinder
werden mit sexuellen Darstellungen
konfrontiert.
Denn Abbildungen von erotischem
Inhalt begegnen uns heute überall
und in jeder nur erdenklichen Form.
Sexualität wurde zuvor als Unter-
drückungsinstrument wahrgenommen.
Es war nicht so, dass die Sexualität
nicht mehr zur Natur gehörte,
sondern: Man ging davon aus, diese
Unterdrückung aufheben zu müssen.
Und dann kommt quasi
die natürliche Sexualität hervor.
Das ist das Narrativ dieser Zeit.
Und das hat schon zu einer
starken Liberalisierung geführt.
Denn Sexualität wurde überhaupt
nicht mehr an die Ehe gekoppelt.
Sexualität war allenfalls
noch mit Liebe verknüpft.
Sexualität war in diesem Sinne
eine Lusterzeugung,
eine Bereicherung
für das Individuum, für das Dasein.
Das ist
ein ganz anderer Blickwinkel.
Die Jungendzeitschrift "Bravo"
wird bis 1972
als jugendgefährdend eingestuft.
Dabei hat sich
mehr als eine Generation
genau dort ihr Basiswissen über Sex
selbst angeeignet.
Dem Team von Dr. Sommer sei Dank.
* Rockige Klänge *
Wenn die alten Normen
nicht mehr stimmen,
wie unterstützt man die Kinder
und die Jugendlichen dann,
damit sie eine befriedigende
Sexualität - wie man damals sagte -
leben können, was braucht es jetzt?
In diesem Zusammenhang kam wieder
der Ruf nach Sexualaufklärung.
Langsam akzeptiert die Gesellschaft
die Realität,
dass Menschen Sex vor der Ehe haben.
Die traditionelle Rollenverteilung
beim Sex,
der Mann ist aktiv, die Frau passiv,
bleibt unangetastet.
Explizite Aufklärungsfilme
sind die Ausnahme.
(Originalton) Näher können zwei
Menschen nicht beieinander sein.
Das ist ein tolles Gefühl für beide,
für den Mann und die Frau.
Er ist gerne in ihr drin und sie mag
es, wenn sie ihn in sich spürt.
D.h.: Liebe machen.
Die Bewegungen beginnen langsam.
Sie werden aber
schneller und schneller,
weil es einen immer
stärker und stärker kitzelt.
Der Mann bewegt seinen Penis in der
Vagina der Frau rauf und runter.
Damit die kitzligen Stellen
aneinander gerieben werden.
Wenn der Mann und die Frau
sich so fest bewegt haben,
dass man fast meint, sie explodie-
ren, dann ist das auch wirklich so.
Das viele Rauf- und Runter-Reiben
endet schliesslich in einer
herrlichen, wunderschönen Explosion.
Dann kommen die 80er-Jahre
mit HIV und Aids.
Die Gewaltthematik
wird viel stärker thematisiert.
Gewalt in der Ehe,
sexuelle Ausbeutung usw.
Und plötzlich
bekommt die Sexualität wieder ...
... etwas Schweres.
Und das erzeugte auf die Aufklärung
und die Sexualerziehung
auch wieder einen
Rückkoppelungseffekt.
Wie in den fast 100 Jahren zuvor
geht es in der Sexualaufklärung
in den 1980er-Jahren
um gefährliche Folgen von Sex,
diesmal ist es HIV -
die sexuell übertragbare Krankheit
Aids.
Wie die Wissenschaft
glaubhaft versichert,
sind Präservative vorläufig
das einzige wirksame Mittel,
um sich vor einer Ansteckung
mit dem Aids-Virus zu schützen.
Dieses kleine Ding kann also
über Leben und Tod entscheiden,
daran ändern weder erotische,
noch ästhetische
oder moralische Bedenken etwas.
"Tagesschau"-Moderator Charles Clerc
zeigt zur Hauptsendezeit
ein Präservativ.
Angesichts der grossen Angst vor Aids
wird etwas möglich,
was undenkbar schien.
Aufklärungskampagnen werden über die
Jahre dem Sexualverhalten angepasst:
Hier sagt man: Der Partner wechselt,
Safer Sex bleibt.
Das greift ein Thema auf,
das heute eine Realität ist.
Wir wissen z.B.,
dass die durchschnittliche Person
im ganzen Leben
sechs bis sieben Sexpartner hat.
Bei jeder fünften Person
sind es über 20.
Es ist also eine Botschaft,
die wohl vielen Leuten nahe ist.
Bescheid wissen,
wie man sich schützen kann.
In diesen Teil
der sexuellen Aufklärung
investieren Bund und Kantone
bis heute.
Und als Aids aufkam,
war es noch wichtiger,
dass jemand wie ich
mit Homosexuellen gesprochen habe,
gesagt habe,
wie sie aufpassen müssen.
Kondome benutzen, wie wichtig
es ist, einen Partner zu haben -
nicht jede Nacht
mit einem anderen ins Bett zu gehen.
Und so habe ich
eine ganze Karriere aufgebaut.
In den 80er-Jahren bekommt auch die
Schweiz eine prominente Sexberaterin.
Marta Emmenegger,
besser bekannt als liebe Marta:
Ich habe schnell gelernt -
weil ich studiert habe
und mich bei Fachleuten
informiert habe -,
dass es
kein persönliches Problem gibt,
das nicht irgendwie
auch die Sexualität berührt.
Dass sexuelle Probleme immer mit
der ganzen übrigen Lebensgeschichte
und der Persönlichkeit des Menschen
zusammenhängen.
Das begann, mich zu faszinieren.
Die "Blick"-Sexkolumnistin
beantwortet täglich
intimste Sex-Fragen der Leserschaft.
Und wird so
zur Aufklärerin der Nation.
Treffen Marta und Dr. Ruth
im Fernsehen aufeinander,
sind gute Einschaltquoten garantiert:
Heute habe ich
eine ganz besondere Überraschung.
Ich habe hier nicht nur
ein fantastisches Publikum,
ich habe die Marta hier bei mir.
Ein gutes Gespräch, mit jemandem,
der etwas davon versteht,
der also nicht sofort
Partei ergreift,
keine lapidaren, oberflächlichen
Ratschläge gibt.
Ein gutes Gespräch,
mit jemandem, der draus kommt,
wie wir in der Schweiz sagen,
kann auch helfen.
Marta, was du hier in der Schweiz
machst und ich in Amerika,
ist genau das,
was du jetzt gesagt hast.
Dieses Gespräch zu öffnen.
Man könnte z.B. einem Paar sagen:
Es ist in Ordnung, wenn man sich
gegenseitig zur Befriedigung bringt,
sich gegenseitig onaniert -
ohne Geschlechtsverkehr.
Bis heute gibt es beim "Blick"
immer noch eine Sexberatung.
Die Psychologin Caroline Fux weiss,
was die Schweiz
unter der Gürtellinie berührt.
Aufklärung
heisst jetzt sexuelle Bildung.
Statt Briefe sind es heute E-Mails.
Aber die Fragen sind geblieben, trotz
sexueller Revolution und Internet.
Online-Dating ist ein grosses,
relativ aktuelles Thema,
das meine Vorgängerinnen
nicht betraf.
Es gibt also Themen, die an
Zeitgeist oder Technologie hängen,
die sich sehr verändern.
Die andere Seite ist dieser Kern,
der lustigerweise -
Sexberatung gibt es nun bald
40 Jahre - immer noch gleich ist.
Da geht es darum,
sich zeigen zu können:
"Bin ich willkommen als Mensch?"
Ein grosser Teil der Sexberatung ist
ja eigentlich auch Liebesberatung.
Es geht um Liebe und Beziehungen.
Wenn ich die Fragen von Marta
von früher lese,
sind das Dinge, die immer noch
in meiner Mailbox sein könnten -
oder wirklich so bei mir ankommen.
Jemand, der unglücklich verliebt
ist, nicht weiss, wie outen.
Oder z.B. eine Dreiecksbeziehung.
Das sind alles
sehr menschliche Themen,
die es ja
schon lange vor Marta gab.
Es gibt also diesen Kern der
sehr urmenschlichen Lebensthemen,
die in jeder Zeit aufkommen.
Das Bedürfnis nach Anleitung
für guten Sex ist so gross wie nie.
Entsprechend umfangreich
ist das Angebot an Aufklärungs-
literatur für Erwachsene -
diskret platziert
im hinteren Teil der Buchhandlung.
Anschauliche Information
bietet auch das Internet.
* Elektronische, rhythmische Musik *
Ich hab mir da ein Modell gekauft.
... die äusseren.
* Sanfte Streicherklänge *
Sexualität ist etwas Gelerntes,
etwas, das man kultivieren muss.
Ich vergleiche es manchmal
mit einer Karriere:
Heute hat - zum Glück -
fast niemand das Gefühl,
eine Karriere passiere einfach so.
Bei der Sexualität
haben wir hingegen das Gefühl,
lustvoller Sex
falle irgendwie vom Himmel.
Lust ist etwas,
worin man auch investieren muss,
man muss sie kultivieren -
sie hat manchmal auch den Charakter
des scheuen Rehs.
Wenn ich mit dem Vorschlaghammer
auf Lust poche,
mache ich z.T. mehr kaputt.
Aber es benötigt Investitionen,
auch ein lustvolles Leben.
Das sehe ich auch oft: Leute kommen
mit unglaublich vollen Terminplänen,
haben sehr enge Strukturen,
viele Zwänge und wenig Raum,
um einfach zu sein
und sich zu entfalten.
Und wenn am Abend
"10vor10" vorbei ist,
alle total erschöpft sind
und im Bett liegen,
dann müsste die Lust explodieren,
der Bär steppen.
So funktioniert es halt
einfach nicht.
Das grosse Tabu
ist heute eigentlich die Lust.
Die Frage, wie man
eine schöne Sexualität haben kann,
kommt in der sexuellen Bildung
momentan sehr wenig vor.
Da wünsche ich mir eine Veränderung.
Sogar im Kindergarten
müssen Kinder wissen,
dass es nicht schmutzig ist,
wenn man sich unten anfasst -
Penis oder Vagina.
Aber privat. Nicht in der Klasse.
Auch für Kinder
gibt es unzählige Bücher.
Jugendliche
suchen und finden
ein immenses visuelles Angebot
im Internet.
Ah, schön klassisch.
Du hast es vielleicht gemerkt,
dank unserem komischen Kamasutra:
Heute geht's bei uns um Sex.
Und zwar um die Frage:
Wie geht Sex eigentlich genau,
gibt es verschiedene Arten von Sex,
wie sieht es mit den Stellungen aus?
Darum geht's heute bei "Dr. Bock".
Hier kommt unser "6-Quickie",
los geht's!
Das Vorspiel: nervig oder nötig?
Das Vorspiel - oder Petting -
ist wichtig, wenn's um Sex geht.
denn man will ja erregt
in die Sache starten,
darum braucht es einen erigierten
Penis und eine feuchte Vagina.
Das kann man mit dem Vorspiel
oder Petting erreichen.
Und es ist ja auch schön, nicht?
Über Sex zu sprechen ist Übungs-
sache - diese Übung fehlt vielen.
Sie fehlt sogar
in intimen Beziehungen -
Ich kenne viele Paare,
die über alles reden können,
sich sehr nahe sind,
eine gute Kommunikation haben.
Aber wenn es um Sexualität geht,
ist es einfach schwierig.
Es kann sein,
dass Leute in einer ersten Phase
ihre Wünsche und Bedürfnisse gar
nicht kennen. So beginnt es oft.
Und sehr oft
fehlt einfach die Sprache.
Sie wissen z.T. theoretisch, wie sie
ein Geschlechtsteil benennen sollen,
aber vielleicht
haben sie Hemmungen:
"Wenn ich Penis sage,
ist das unromantisch."
Oder: "Wenn ich Vagina sage, klingt
das nach der Gynäkologiestunde."
Wir haben sehr wenig Praxis
im Reden über echten Sex.
Ob Porno oder Aufklärung -
Jugendliche
suchen ihre Antworten im Internet.
Mega eklig.
- Was ist das?
Altersbeschränkungen
sind leicht zu umgehen.
Man geht ins Internet,
schreibt ein Y,
dann kommt YouPorn
und man klickt drauf.
Dann wird gefragt, ob man 18 ist,
da klickt man Ja.
Das wahllose Anklicken
von Sexseiten im Internet
hat nichts mit Aufklärung zu tun -
im Gegenteil.
Tatsache ist,
dass Kinder und Jugendliche
oft schon Pornos gesehen haben,
bevor sie erste sexuelle Erfahrungen
machen.
Die Jugend von heute schaut sehr oft
pornografische Filme.
Ob sie das auch in eine Beziehung
mitnehmen - das ist die Frage.
Denn was man
in der Pornografie sieht,
dass ein Mann
eine zehnstündige Erektion hat,
vom Boden bis zur Decke -
das ist Quatsch!
Das gibt's doch nur im Film.
Und da entstehen viele Probleme.
Auch wenn man z.B. zeigt,
dass Frauen in diesen Filmen einen
Orgasmus haben, der 10 Min. dauert.
Das gibt's nicht!
Und das ist das Problem.
Man braucht weiterhin
gute sexuelle Erziehung.
Mit Daten - von Büchern, von
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen,
damit man sagt:
Wir können über diese Dinge sprechen
und wir müssen darüber sprechen.
Man sollte wirklich aufhören
mit der alten Geschichte vom Storch.
Wie vor 100 oder vor 50 Jahren -
Aufklärungsgespräche
waren und sind anspruchsvoll:
Ich wurde mit Freunden aufgeklärt.
Man kann die Eltern
nicht alles fragen.
Ich würde behaupten, als ich 13
oder 14 war, versuchte der Lehrer,
das im Unterricht mit Kondom
und Besenstiel zu erklären.
Bei mir zu Hause waren Sex
und sexuelle Aufklärung tabu.
Also in der Schule, durch Schul-
freunde, vielleicht mal ein Buch.
Aber keine richtige Aufklärung.
Die meisten Informationen von meinen
Eltern, aber auch aus dem Internet.
In der Schule noch sehr wenig.
Wir hatten in der Schule
keine Sexual... Wie sagt man?
Sexualkunde.
Das hatten wir nicht.
Das gab es noch nicht.
Man hat immer das Gefühl,
die Kinder wissen heute alles.
Aber wenn es um dieses Thema geht,
sind sie irgendwie verloren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich
mit meinen Eltern darüber sprach.
Es war ein bisschen kompliziert,
mit der Mutter darüber zu sprechen.
Es ist peinlich.
Ja, das ist zu akzeptieren.
Das ist wohl einfach so.
Dass man sich die wichtigen Infos
zu diesem Thema bei Freunden holt.
Peinlich, mega peinlich.
Mit Eltern über so was zu sprechen -
man ist sich das nicht gewohnt.
Wenn das im Haushalt
nicht normal ist, ist es peinlich,
wenn es heisst: "Komm, wir setzen
uns hin und reden darüber."
In der Schule ist es genauso pein-
lich, aber man ist nicht alleine.
Darum gibt es heute
für Neun- bis Elfjährige
neue Angebote der Aufklärung.
Mit sog. MFM-Agenten
und in Zyklusshows
lernen Buben und Mädchen getrennt,
was im Körper passiert
und wie sie lustvoll und
wertschätzend damit umgehen können.
Aber nicht jede Schule kann oder will
sich diese Aufklärungskurse leisten.
Ein totes Spermium,
komm lass dir helfen.
Dieses Spermium ist ziemlich fit,
ich möchte euch die gerne erklären.
Da ist was extrem Kompliziertes
und extrem Wertvolles drin.
Weiss jemand,
was das sein könnte?
Der Bauplan des Vaters,
wie er ist, seine Hobbies etc.
Und das Gleiche von der Mutter.
Und dann werden sie diskutieren ...
Woher weisst du das alles?
- Ich war schon mal hier!
Weiss jemand von euch,
wer der Chef im Körper ist?
Man sagte immer:
"Hallo, Mr. Hypophyse, Chef!"
Wer ist der Chef in unserem Körper,
Timo? - Der Penis.
Okay - könnte sein, meistens nicht,
nur manchmal vielleicht.
Es gibt noch einen,
der übergeordnet ist,
wer ist der wirkliche Chef und
entscheidet, was im Körper passiert?
Wo sitzt der?
- Das Hirn.
Der Mr. Hypophyse sitzt
nicht im Penis, sondern im Gehirn.
Ihr werdet jetzt
auf die Reise gehen -
dafür müsst ihr
komplett ausgerüstet sein.
* Lachen, Stimmengewirr *
Das Siegerspermium heisst Timo!
Lies bitte vor, was da steht, Timo.
"Du hast es geschafft. Du darfst
unsere Mission erfolgreich beenden."
Bitte, du darfst das einführen.
So z.B.
Jetzt haben wir
eine lebende Eizelle.
Eine Sexualisierung gibt es
durch Aufklärung sicher nicht.
Es gibt inzwischen verschiedene
Untersuchungen weltweit,
die nachweisen,
dass Sexualaufklärung
das Alter der ersten Sexualität
nach hinten verschiebt.
Das ist auch unser Ansatz:
Man geht verantwortlicher mit
Sexualität um, weiss mehr darüber.
Man stolpert viel schneller
ahnungslos in Dinge hinein,
wenn man nichts darüber weiss.
Bildung trägt dazu bei,
dass man gut damit umgeht.
Sexualisieren im Sinne von schla-
fende Hunde wecken, aufstacheln -
das geht mit so einer Vermittlung
nicht.
Sexuelle Übergriffe sexualisieren,
wenn Kinder
sexuelle Erfahrungen machen.
Das kann dazu führen, dass sie
auch sexuelles Verhalten zeigen -
das nennt man Sexualisieren.
Sexualaufklärung sexualisiert nicht,
sie informiert.
Dieses Eibläschen
ist noch grösser geworden.
Und auf der Oberfläche bilden sich
immer noch mehr beste Freundinnen.
Einen Tag lang
lernen die Kinder vor allem eines:
Alles, was im Körper passiert,
ist normal.
Das Wichtigste ist,
darüber Bescheid zu wissen.
Nach dem Motto: Nur was man schätzt,
kann man schützen.
Verliebt sein, sich selbst
kennenlernen, sich entdecken.
Da gibt es Mädchen, die sich
nicht einen Jungen verlieben,
sondern in ein anderes Mädchen.
Wisst ihr, wie man das benennt?
Ja, Marva?
Homosexuell?
- Richtig.
Das ist richtig.
Ganz oben hat es noch etwas
Spezielles, die sog. Klitoris.
Das ist ein ganz empfindsamer,
kleiner Bereich,
der dann beim Empfinden,
bei der Sexualität, bei der Lust
eine sehr grosse Rolle spielt.
Es lohnt sich, da ganz im Ver-
borgenen, ihr für euch, alleine,
einen Spiegel zu nehmen und
diese Sache genau zu inspizieren.
* Eurovisionsmelodie *
Voila - wir haben es geschafft.
Es ist zur ersten Periode gekommen.
Das ist einen Applaus wert, oder?
Sie zelebrieren die Periode
als ein positives Ereignis.
Ja mit dieser Periode und so ...
Das finde ich eigentlich spannend
und es ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich finde eigentlich,
es ist nicht so eklig.
Denn es ist halt normal.
Die Jugendlichen
haben viel Halbwissen.
Und ich mit meinem Hintergrund
finde Halbwissen eine Katastrophe.
Denn für eine Frau ist Halbwissen
und falsches Wissen fatal.
Unter gewissen Umständen.
Ich bin eine Verfechterin
von richtigen Informationen, Basics.
Denn wenn man den Körper
falsch interpretiert,
weil im Buch steht, man sei am
14. Tag nach der Periode fruchtbar -
das stimmt dann einfach nicht.
Dann ist eine junge Frau
irgendwann einfach schwanger.
Sie muss ihren Körper
individuell lesen können.
Das steht in keiner App, nirgends
im Internet, das muss sie lernen.
Längst nicht alle Schweizer Kinder
können an diesen Aufklärungskursen
teilnehmen.
Der Bund
delegiert die Aufgabe an die Kantone.
Diesen
fehlt eine einheitliche Strategie.
Den Schulen oft
die finanziellen Mittel.
Hinzu kommt,
dass konservative Kreise Druck machen
gegen sexuelle Aufklärung
auf Primarschulstufe -
2013 auf politischem Weg:
"Keine Sexualkunde
für unter Neunjährige",
lautet die zentrale Forderung
einer heute lancierten Initiative.
Kleine Kinder müssten vor Sexual-
kunde-Unterricht geschützt werden.
Laut den Initianten,
die aus den Reihen der SVP, FDP
und CVP unterstützt werden,
kommt dieser einer staatlich
geförderten Sexualisierung gleich,
die dringend gestoppt werden müsse.
Sexualerziehung solle nicht
in der Schule stattfinden,
sondern Sache der Eltern bleiben -
die Initiative will dies
in der Schweizerischen
Bundesverfassung verankern.
Die Initiative
wird zwar zurückgezogen.
Aber christlich-konservative Kreise
wehren sich nach wie vor dagegen.
Gegen Werte und Ansichten,
die ihrem Weltbild widersprechen.
Sie lehnen z.B. ab,
dass Sex unter Schwulen und Lesben
als normal gelten soll.
Die Schule ist nicht dazu da,
Werte zu vermitteln.
Mich stört v.a., dass wir Eltern
keinen Einfluss mehr nehmen können.
Es ist alles erlaubt,
es ist alles gut.
Wir zeigen Ihnen mal ein Beispiel.
Das Beispiel "Hotnights",
ein Lehrmittel für die Oberstufe,
vom Bund finanziert.
Die Geschichte von Jugendlichen
an einem Open Air.
Das Open Air heisst Hotnights.
Es gibt da ein bisschen von allem.
Das ist das Paar, das zum ersten Mal
Sex hat an diesem Open Air.
Johnny:
"Bin solo und so was von spitz".
Das ist eine Animation, die sagt:
"Folge deiner Lust!"
Die Moral dabei
wird einfach darauf reduziert,
dass man ein Kondom haben muss,
es einvernehmlich sein muss.
Und das war's.
In den 90er-Jahren kristallisierte
sich eine neue Sexualethik heraus.
Die neue Sexualethik
ist die sog. Verhandlungsmoral.
Weil es ganz klar war:
Jede Frau, jeder Mann,
jedes Individuum
muss für sich selbst bestimmen,
was man will.
Es gibt ein Menschenrecht
auf sexuelle Aufklärung.
Die Schweiz hat die UNO-Konvention
unterschrieben.
D.h. der Staat hat die Pflicht,
die Kinder sexuell aufzuklären.
Und ihnen auch
ihre Rechte zu vermitteln.
Die Schulärztin Claudia Landerer
besucht mit ihrem Aufklärungskoffer
die Biologieklassen
an der Kantonsschule Wetzikon.
Seit elf Jahren ist sie
als Dr. Sex an Schulen unterwegs:
Mich erstaunt immer wieder, dass
Jugendliche trotz des vielen Wissens
doch noch so viele Fragen haben.
Alle hatten ja
schon einmal Aufklärung.
Ich erinnere mich
an eine spezielle Situation.
Ich mache auch gynäkologische
Routineuntersuchungen.
Da frage ich die Frauen meist, ob
sie Sexualität befriedigend erleben.
Mit dem Mann, oder wie das so ist.
Da habe ich auch schon erlebt,
dass mir eine 45-jährige Frau,
Mutter von drei Kindern, sagte:
"Ich muss Ihnen etwas gestehen,
ich hatte in meinem Leben
noch nie einen Orgasmus."
Und das ist ja unglaublich.
Klar, vielleicht
wuchs sie in religiösen Kreisen auf,
wo das kein Thema war.
Und klar, um Kinder zu bekommen,
braucht eine Frau keinen Orgasmus.
Aber etwas, das die Natur
allen Menschen gegeben hat,
ein Glücksgefühl,
das man nicht kaufen muss,
aber erleben
und auch fördern kann ...
Ja, etwas Schönes zu haben,
das nichts kostet.
Dass das nicht selbstverständlich
ist, ist schon speziell.
Kann ich Schweizerdeutsch sprechen,
verstehen das alle?
Die 15-jährigen Gymnasiast/-innen
haben am Vortag
anonym Fragen aufgeschrieben.
Mündlich
würde sich kaum jemand melden.
Offen zum Thema Sex Fragen zu stellen
ist wie eh und je unangenehm.
Also, ich habe die Fragen
ein wenig geordnet,
damit wir durchkommen -
es sind viele.
Z.B. diese hier: "Ab wann
sollte man zum Frauenarzt?"
Wichtig für euch ist:
Um die Antibabypille zu bekommen,
muss man nicht unbedingt
zum Frauenarzt,
jeder Arzt in der Schweiz
kann die Pille verschreiben.
Und auch wichtig ist: Für die
Verschreibung der Antibabypille
benötigt es keinen gynäkologischen
Untersuch.
Wenn ihr aber zu einem Frauenarzt
geht und die Antibabypille wollt,
dann sagt der meistens:
"Zieh dich mal aus,
wir schauen, ob das geht."
Dann sollten bei euch
die Alarmglocken läuten.
Wenn ihr euch eigentlich nicht
untersuchen lassen wollt, sagt das.
Denn die heutige Universitätsmeinung
besagt:
Für die Verschreibung der Pille
braucht es keinen Untersuch.
Man fragt nur - man misst
den Blutdruck und das Gewicht.
"Wie viel Geschlechtsverkehr
hat ein durchschnittlicher Mensch
pro Woche?"
Bei solchen Fragen
ergibt es keinen Sinn,
irgendeine Statistik
oder eine Zahl zu nennen.
Ihr sollt nur das machen,
was ihr für euch gut findet.
Folgt ja nicht
irgendeinem Bild.
Zwei miteinander - da müsst ihr
zusammen schauen, wie das ist.
Ich hatte auch schon junge Frauen,
die sagten:
"Mein Freund will am Wochenende
zehnmal am Tag mit mir schlafen,
ich finde das nicht lustig,
nicht angenehm."
Da muss man sagen:
"Nein, ich will das nicht."
Man muss miteinander einen Weg
finden, sodass es gut ist.
Ich bin da komplett gegen Zahlen.
Die Lust findet im Gehirn statt.
Die kann vorhanden sein oder nicht -
bei Jungen und bei Alten.
Sie ist nicht direkt hormonabhängig.
Lust auf Sex, auch sexueller Genuss
passiert im Kopf. Eine Art Kopfkino.
Je mehr Erfahrung man
mit Sexualität hat,
desto besser wird es meistens.
"Kann die Frau oder der Mann
durch Stimulation an den Nippeln
einen Orgasmus haben
oder geil werden?"
Was würdet ihr nun sagen?
Wer traut sich, etwas zu sagen? Ja?
Ich denke schon.
- Ja, weil es so ein Kopfkino ist.
Wenn man sich vorstellt:
"Das fände ich mega geil",
da kann man sich stimulieren lassen
und sagt vielleicht auch:
"Ich mag es, wenn du mich hinter
dem Ohr leckst" - oder so etwas.
Es sind also nicht einfach
nur die Geschlechtsteile
und meistens sind die Frauen
dort etwas vielfältiger.
Die Männer sind meistens
sehr auf den Penis fixiert,
aber sie können es genauso lernen,
mehr ...
Das anders zu erleben.
"Bei welchen
Geschlechtsverkehrsarten
kann die Frau schwanger werden?"
Wie denkt ihr z.B. könnte man
beim Oralverkehr schwanger werden?
Wisst ihr, was Oralverkehr ist?
Oralverkehr, das würde heissen,
er ejakuliert in den Mund eines
anderen Manns, einer anderen Frau.
Und dann, kann sie schwanger
werden beim Oralverkehr?
Ja? - Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Das Sperma muss in die Scheide
kommen, damit sie schwanger wird.
Genau.
Das wird einfach verdaut,
wenn man es schluckt.
Der Magen ist so sauer,
da löst sich alles auf.
Das wär's, sorry,
wir haben ein wenig überzogen.
Ich bin noch kurz hier, falls ihr
etwas persönlich fragen möchtet.
Sonst wisst ihr, wie ihr mich
erreichen könnt: schulaerztin*kzo.
Oder eine Sprechstunde vereinbaren.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch was gebracht.
Vielen Dank.
- Bitte.
Was nimmst du von dieser Stunde mit?
Ja, dass vieles verschieden ist,
dass man Lust auch
ganz verschieden empfinden kann.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Und dass es von der Kultur abhängig
ist, wie man verhütet.
Warum ist es wichtig, dass
Frau Landerer in die Klassen kommt?
Es ist wichtig, dass wir darüber
Bescheid wissen,
denn es ist ein grosses Thema
in diesem Alter.
Ich finde es wichtig, dass wir
auf unsere Sicherheit achten.
Ja, dieser Aspekt.
Aber ihr hättet ja auch im Internet
nachschauen können, oder?
Ja, aber so ist es besser -
im Internet steht viel Unsinn,
Google hat nicht immer recht.
Je mehr man weiss, aufgeklärt ist,
desto mehr passiert einem nicht,
sondern man kann wählen, man weiss,
was man will und was nicht.
Es geht mir um das Emotionale,
Rechtliche, Beziehungsmässige,
Soziale.
Diese Norm von aussen
gibt es nicht mehr.
D.h. aber auch, dass die Verant-
wortung dem Individuum gegeben wird.
Und das Individuum - resp. wenn
Sexualität im Paar gelebt wird,
dann muss das Paar aushandeln,
was gelebt und zugelassen wird
und was nicht.
Das ist quasi die Ethik,
die wir heute haben.
Sexuell aufgeklärt zu sein
bedeutet heute, zu wissen:
Jeder Mensch hat ein Recht auf Lust
am und mit dem eigenen Körper.
Unabhängig von Geschlecht, Alter,
Kultur oder Religion.
Bitte masturbieren.
Sich selbst befriedigen.
Nicht in der Öffentlichkeit!
Nicht im Fernsehen.
Nicht in den Bergen,
wo jemand dazukommen kann.
Sondern wenn ihr alleine seid.
Es ist besser, sich selbst
zur Befriedigung zu bringen,
als den ganzen Tag
frustriert zu sein.
Laut und klar für die Schweiz!
* Aufgestellte Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2019